i just learned that over an hour ago an
eight-year-old girl was shot in the head
she's in surgery now fighting for her
life
and the question is is there any hope
for chicago
this past tuesday six children were shot
within 24 hours
in an earlier rooftop revelation i said
it was five kids when it was actually
six
is there any hope
for chicago
the chaos the lawlessness is so bad in
chicago that the criminals openly mock
our police and our city leaders
and even our governor
two criminals broke into two stores and
stole the cash registers they took out
the cash and they drove over to governor
pritzker's home in chicago
and you know what they did
they left the empty registers on his
front lawn
if that isn't a message that the
criminals running the city
i don't know what is then you know what
they did those same criminals right
after they did that they joined other
criminals and began to rob other stores
is there any hope for chicago
i'm gonna tell you something i usually
am mild-mannered
and even killed and
but this wave of violence i'm telling
you it infuriates me it it just
infuriates me
i've been working to counter this
violence and despair for so long through
project good
and my community center that that's
housed on the second floor of our church
and before we started this very area was
ranked as the most dangerous
neighborhood in all of chicago
now because of our work it doesn't even
make the list you know why
because we gave people in our community
the most valuable thing you can give
anyone
hope
we gave them hope by building a
relationship with the police to get the
criminals off the street
we gave them hope by giving them a way
out through
trades and vocational training and rehab
we gave them hope by helping them to
get off drugs and
we we gave them hope by
showing young men how to be fathers so
they could break the cycle of
fatherlessness in their families
we gave single mothers hope by providing
male role models for
their young boys their young daughters
and wait and what makes me so angry and
infuriates me is that we see our leaders
mocking our efforts with their
wishy-washy ideas like defund the police
come on man
the police are not our enemy
equity initiatives come on we need
equity equality of opportunity
all of this race talk in the classrooms
come on we need traditional
and rigorous education
i'm not here to brag about project good
i don't have to
just look at our track record that's why
i'm on this roof to build this huge
facility so we can scale up and that we
the work that we've been doing for so
long so it can reach more people
our leaders are going the wrong
direction an eight-year-old girl is in
surgery right now
how many more will it take before our
leaders wake up
you know what
they'll never wake up
you know why
they don't care
but we do we're in the streets every day
and we and other similar organizations
around the city are our best hope so yes
there is hope in chicago it starts with
the people not our leaders
all of them are bankrupt we know
what we must do to get the job done
we must continue to put it to work we
must continue to strive in the midst of
struggle
we must continue to reach out to our
fellow brothers and sisters and show
them that a different path give them the
hope that they need so yes there is hope
in chicago
and it starts
with all of us